president trump is forcing a national
embarrassment on all of us by not
yet conceding an election to
presidential candidate
joe biden that is at least the story
according to presidential candidate
joe biden sir what do you say to the
americans that are anxious over the fact
that president trump has yet to concede
and what that might mean for the country
well um i just think it's an
embarrassment
quite frankly uh the only thing that uh
how can i say this uh tactfully i think
it will not
help the president's legacy i think
that i know from my discussions with
four leaders thus far that
they are hopeful that the united states
democratic institutions are viewed once
again as being strong and endured
and uh but i think at the end of the day
you know it's all going to come to
fruition on january 20th
and between now and then i hope an
expectation is that the american people
are do know do understand that there has
been a transition
yeah we do understand that there's been
a transition there's been a transition
from the
election into the legal process that
will determine the next
president you know what i think is a
national embarrassment the fact that
there's
even a possibility that this daughtering
crook liar plagiarist could
possibly become the president but he
isn't the president yet there's a whole
lot of
hoops to jump through before we find out
who the next president will be
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show joe biden an
absolute embarrassment
that's what they say this gets me so hot
under the collar
this gets me so fuming so stressed out
that we've got to go through this
nonsense not merely the legal process
of determining who the next president
will be but also counter
the completely uniform media narrative
it gets me so pent up full of energy
the only way i can get it out is with my
rad power bike
i strongly recommend you get a rad power
bike
it can take you around town it can take
you around nature whatever you want to
do it's a great way to get outdoors
without getting too hot or too sweaty
they're tons of fun you know what rad
power bikes do
they can go up to 20 miles per hour
without pedaling
so that you can get out and about but
you don't need to work too hard to do it
they're also very affordable
most e-bikes are in the 3 000 range you
know me i'm a little bit more frugal i
don't necessarily want to spend that
rad power bikes start at just 999 most
are under
1500 bucks they're really really cool
it's a great hobby it's also a great way
to commute especially these days as
traffic is starting to pick back up
again
i i think they're just absolutely
terrific it also makes a great gift for
someone
who loves being active and loves being
outdoors right now for a limited time
rad power bikes offers flexible
financing for as low as
0 apr that is as good as you can
possibly get
plus free shipping bikes are going to go
super fast
they they already are actually so make
sure that you order right away text
knowles k-n-w-l-e-s to sixty four
thousand today get free shipping that is
knowles can
wlas to sixty four thousand text knolls
to 64 000.
we are possibly going to transition
possibly i say
to a president who doesn't know how to
text numbers do you remember you just
had to go to joe
30330 that would be very embarrassing
if that man were to become president but
he hasn't yet i felt
secretary of state mike pompeo had a
much better answer on this
he was he was asked as part of this
media narrative that the race which has
not been called has been called
and that we know that joe biden is going
to be president we don't know that
we won't know that for quite some time
he had a great answer on it
as to how he's going to handle the
transition is the state department
currently preparing to engage with the
biden transition team and if not
at what point does a delay hamper a
smooth transition or pose a risk to
national security
there will be a smooth transition to a
second trump administration
all right we're ready the world is
watching what's taking place here we're
going to count all the votes
when the process is complete there'll be
electors selected there's a process the
constitution lays it out pretty clearly
the world should have every confidence
that the transition necessary to make
sure that the state department is
functional today
successful today and successful with the
president who's
in office on january 20th a minute
afternoon
will also be successful that is what an
adult sounds like that's what a
responsible
politician sounds like he has a bit of a
joke you know
they say are you ready for the
transition he says i'm absolutely ready
for the transition into a second term
and he says look what will the
transition be we may get a second term
we may not get a second term
but we are going to follow the legal
process the idea that joe biden is
suggesting that this is a great
embarrassment
that we don't know who the president is
yet first of all if that is an
embarrassment that is that
embarrassment is the fault of democrats
who forced widespread unsolicited mail
in voting on us
unprecedented has never happened before
and they knew they admitted at the time
that if you have widespread unsolicited
mail in voting you're not going to know
who the president is
on election night and it's kind of
interesting if you look at how the votes
were counted
that it seemed to shift from president
trump
to joe biden in the middle of the night
sometimes when they said there weren't
even votes being counted in certain
places
and without republican poll watchers
notably in philadelphia
so yes a legal process will play out
bush v gore how long did that take 38
days or so
total i don't remember joe biden calling
it an embarrassment
that al gore would not concede in that
election even though he had no evidence
whatsoever
that that election could be overturned
no that is not an embarrassment
what is an embarrassment is that people
want to break our constitutional norms
which clearly provide a legal process
for how this election is going to go the
media haven't learned that maybe the
media have learned that and they they
just
want to play dumb and for some members
of the media they don't have to play
too hard at playing dumb i actually
a member of msnbc admitted this so
right now and i think this story people
are not talking about it
there's a battle between democrats and
republicans okay
there's another battle going on and mike
pompeo is alluding to this which is the
foreign policy battle and there it's not
so much republican democrat
as elected people
the american people speaking through
their elected representatives
and the deep state the permanent
bureaucracy which is most pronounced
in the intelligence community and in
foreign policy that is where these guys
who are the true swamp creatures that is
where they tend to live
bill crystal talked about this and other
national security republicans you know
the types
who just don't really care about what's
going on too much at the domestic level
they just want to force their particular
liberal internationalism on everybody
bill crystal was asked if you had to
choose between the deep state of the
swamp state what do you pick
he says i choose i'm sorry the deep
state of the trump state he said
i choose the deep state which is to say
he chooses the swamp state
that is a big battle going on right now
and you're going to see in the coming
days
the intelligence community the state
department foreign policy that is going
to be brought
far up to the forefront because you had
a foreign policy consensus
basically since bush the first
if not even earlier than that and the
president would change you had bush you
had clinton you had bush you had obama
and the foreign policy wouldn't change
they would there was a joke in 2008 they
said
they told me if i voted for john mccain
we'd get another war in the middle east
and that was true i voted for john
mccain we got another war in the middle
east
obama's foreign policy was basically
indistinguishable
from mccain's foreign policy maybe obama
gave a little more money to iran but in
terms of the constant wars the
never-ending wars
that was the same policy you didn't you
didn't see that really change at all
the policy of bombing saddam hussein
every so often that had been going on
for a very long for a very long time so
that battle is going to come up and the
media haven't learned a thing here
this msnbc host i guess he thought his
microphone was off i guess he thought
the camera was off
but he was asked what he knows and i
thought he gave a very precise
ken answer has some new reporting on
something that we talked about at the
top of the hour
how the trump administration is handling
the transition
with the incoming biden team or not
handling it we should say to a certain
extent this
time it involves our intelligence
community
uh ken what have you learned sir
okay uh i think we lost i think we lost
ken for a second we'll try to get him
back there
now they thought this was a mistake now
they thought this
was a mistake that it was accidental i
don't think so i think that was a very
precise answer what have you learned
not very much i can't use the words
because i'll i'll have to be bleeped out
myself
so that's pretty pretty fair that should
be the headline what is the media
learned
blank blank absolutely blank but then
they cut back to him
they cut back to the guy and and he
makes his point and you hear on the
premise that the biden
president-elect biden is transitioning
in
the election hasn't been called but he's
transitioning how is this going to work
for the intelligence community hey craig
first i want to sincerely apologize to
viewers who may have heard some
uh me use profanity at the top of the at
the last hit but what we're learning
today
is the potential impact of the
resistance of the trump administration
to acknowledge the biden win in the
intelligence arena specifically
the intelligence community why do i
care what the intelligence community
thinks about
a duly elected president or in the case
here a not
dually elected president someone who we
don't know who the president is going to
be
why do i care what the intelligence
community thinks i like the intelligence
community when they do their job well
that's good i guess it helps our
national security
i despise the intelligence community
when they decide that they are going to
take our republic into their own hands
and try to undermine or overturn an
election as they did in 2015 and as they
did in 2016.
this is what would be one of the
greatest losses
if president trump ultimately does not
prevail in this election
if joe biden is named president one of
the great losses
is that the deep state blob will
solidify
will reform and president trump has done
a great job of exposing these guys
had hillary clinton won in 2016 we would
have had
no idea no idea that the deep state
under the obama administration spied on
the trump campaigns
used the weapons of the state to spy on
their political opponents we would have
had no idea
that they cooked up phony intelligence
with the hillary campaign and the dnc
to try to frame president trump which
led to a mueller investigation
for however many millions of dollars in
two and a half years which led to
a fraudulent impeachment which led to so
much because of these particular leaks
chuck schumer admitted this early on
when trump said i'm going to clean up
the deep state particularly the
intelligence community
chuck schumer said you should never go
against the intelligence community
they can kill you nine ways from sunday
they can get you
so many different ways they got dirt on
everybody don't go up
against them that is what he said and i
think it was actually probably good
advice to president trump
trump fortunately though had some
courage and stood against it what do i
i don't care that the intelligence
community wants joe biden installed
president before the legal process plays
out does nothing to me
you know senator cruz who is not just
my favorite u.s senator but my podcast
co-host
over at verdict senator cruz took a
really great swing
at the deep state yesterday he had andy
mccabe that crooked fbi official
who was deeply implicated in all the
hoaxes of the past few years
and the the spying on president trump's
campaign he got him on the hill
and he grilled him on his wrongdoing
did james comey authorize you to
disclose
information about the clinton foundation
investigation
to the press
i didn't need james comey's
authorization i didn't ask if you needed
it i asked
did he authorize you to disclose it
that's a yes or no question
i authorize the disclosure okay you're
still not answering
my question did james comey know about
it and did he authorize it yes or no did
he know about it
to my recollection sir yes he knew about
it did he authorize you did he did you
did he in any way give you the green
light explicitly or implicitly
i didn't ask jim comey i'm not asking
whether you asked i'm asking
okay according to washington times april
18 2018 mr mccabe insisted he told his
boss that
that he had authorized disclosure about
the clinton investigation but mr comey
has denied this claim
uh and mr mccabe told investigators that
mr comey knew he had authorized
disclosure and agreed it was a good idea
is that accurate is that your testimony
to this committee
that is my recollection oh finally we
get an answer now
that's terrific that's wonderful thank
you mr mccabe it only took
700 tries this is the thing about
senator cruz
that most impresses me i do not say this
to flatter him
or because i'm he's a friend of mine or
because we've got the show together
i say this because he is better at this
than any elected republican i know
he can grill down to the heart of the
argument
and he can sniff out when someone is
giving him bs
basically unlike anything i've ever seen
you saw right at the beginning he goes
did james comey authorize this and
mccabe goes well
yeah i didn't i didn't ask james guy did
i ask you if you asked james comey well
i i
and it doesn't seem to be answer the
question buddy and it's
it really puts you off off your guard i
remember
senator cruz did this to mark zuckerberg
one time he uh
he was asking him basically
hey mr zuckerberg why is what color is
the sky oh sky's blue yeah hey mr
zuckerberg
does two plus two equal four yeah yeah
it equals four okay hey
mark zuckerberg why was palmer lucky
fired and it it just
kind of throws you off balance and
finally you get an answer
like we saw here but the other the other
line that cruz uses
very smart it obviously comes from his
courtroom experience is
he doesn't ask a question he doesn't
know the answer to so he knew those
answers the entire time
and then he nails mccabe you're aware
that your testimony is 180 degrees
opposite mr comey's sworn testimony
to this committee in which he insisted
he has never authorized
anybody to leak to the press
i i don't i'm not gonna say what
director comey said or didn't say to you
that would
however your characterization of a leak
is not accurate the fbi has records that
will establish whether you're telling
the truth or mr comey's telling the
truth do you believe the fbi should make
those records public so if you're
telling
the truth you can be vindicated and if
mr comey's telling the truth he can be
vindicated
i'm not sure what records you're
referring to uh senator any and all
emails
correspondence records whatsoever
indicating that mr comey knew of your
leaks and authorized them
i would very much like to see those
records as well as would i
thank you as would i and
i believe senator cruz immediately after
that
exchange went out and drafted a letter
to chris wray at the fbi
and to bill barr the attorney general to
let those records open up
it can get a little confusing in this
exchange because we're talking about all
these arcane details
but what it comes down to is when we're
talking about the disclosure of the
investigation of the clinton foundation
when we're talking about all the
shenanigans
that have been going on at the fbi and
doj for the past
uh four years but notably when when
james comey was in charge there
you're getting conflicting stories from
andy mccabe
and from james comey why well you're
getting conflicting stories now because
jim
andy mccabe knows that he doesn't want
to perjure himself he knows that it's a
crime
to lie under oath and he's a slippery
guy but he is not going to implicate
himself in that crime
so now you've got these two guys going
after one another
regardless of whether or not president
trump gets a second term
it's very important to expose these guys
now it is
very important to dig up as much of the
swamp
as is possible the president's done a
good job so far
he's got to ramp that up now this is the
time to make it happen because
under a prospective biden administration
none of that is going to happen and
these weasels who are taking away
your constitutional rights and your
political power
these weasels are going to get away with
it if we don't take care of it now
and i think every other u.s senator on
the republican side should be doing
exactly what senator cruz did today
and i hope that the attorney general and
the director of the fbi
will release records i mean this is
something president trump could do right
now
it would be wonderful
release declassify any and
all records that can expose these
political
monsters these deep state swamp
creatures
that are undermining our constitutional
government
declassify them you know who has the
right to declassify
whatever he wants the president of the
united states
talk about a smooth transition do we
want a smooth transition
to a swamp creature or do we want to
give the people
what they voted for in 2016 at least a
little bit
in the event that we are not
transitioning into a second trump term
and we very well
may be but we've got to be prepared it's
very important to be prepared it's
very important to be ready that's why we
love our friends over at ready wise
now is a better time than ever to be
prepared
with long term nutritional food options
ready wise has a ton of
options you know this emergency meals
freeze dried fruits and vegetables for
convenient on the go nutrition
new adventure meals for hiking camping
and other outdoor activities now
because of increased demand supplies are
limited right now
some items may currently be out of stock
you got to call in quick
when government resources are strained
it can be days
it can be weeks before fresh food is
available do not put yourself in this
situation
i think we conservatives know it's
important to be
prepared for any event it gives you
peace of mind and for me that's what i
want
also there there was an instance where
we had ready wise meals around the
office and i noticed they were
disappearing
and i asked one of my producers was
eating them for lunch just all the time
there was we were not under insurrection
he just felt they were delicious you add
water they were excellent
right now my listeners can get free
shipping at readywise.com when entering
knowles kowles at checkout
or by calling 855-453-2945
readywise has a 90 day no questions
asked return policy you're not going to
need that
there's no risk in taking the initiative
to get yourself and your family prepared
today that is readywise
r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e.com
promo code knowles k-w-l-e-s to get
free shipping we have to
expose the corrupt spooks there is a
role for spooks in government
there have been many spies who have done
many very good things to help the
national interest of the united states
but there are a lot of crooked spooks
too
like these people in the deep state some
of whom occasionally have to testify
there's one career spook that may drive
me the craziest of all though
and that man's name is egg mcmuffin egg
mr
evan mcmullen who ran valiantly
against president trump in 2016. he was
going to be the conservative alternative
because he was a career at the at the
cia and then he worked on the hill for a
little bit and then he was an investment
banker and he was going to be the
wonderful
alternative to that monster that terror
unconservative man donald trump
and thankfully he didn't win he got
about four votes
and and it's uh and he's proven himself
to be unworthy of the public trust every
day since then
it's funny because you know i had this
disagreement in 2016 with jeremy boring
we agreed on many many aspects of the
election but i
though i was skeptical about whether or
not trump would be a new york democrat
or whether he'd be a conservative i
voted for him i felt the alternative was
so
awful that i was willing to take a
chance on trump and i'm glad i did
jeremy voted for egg mcmuffin because he
just
he was too skeptical of trump and he
says now he says look i think it was
still defensible to be very skeptical of
trump in 2016. but
i do regret voting for the egg mcmuffin
because the egg mcmuffin
has has exposed what he really is and
what too much of our
intelligence community has become eggman
muffin just tweets out
quote we should keep and publish a list
of everyone who assists trump's
frivolous and dangerous attacks on the
election name
and shame forever he is just the latest
to join in on this attack on our
free government which is to say that we
need enemy lists
anybody who supports the president you
saw this from the trump accountability
project
who says that we need to publish lists
we need to go after people who
supported trump worked for trump or
funded trump you know anybody
anybody on the right the real right not
the fake egg mcmuffin liberal right
aoc has suggested this sort of thing a
lot of people have
and now we've got the allegedly
wonderful conservative guy i got to tell
you something the fact
that this guy was a spook for so many
years that he had access to some
information that the rest of us did not
have access to that he had the
protection
of various clearances that doesn't make
me feel very good about our government i
don't know what this guy did overseas
but i don't like
that he had any sort of covert
powers in this country because he's
obviously a petty little tyrant
who should be kept away from the levers
of power forever they talk about trump
as an authoritarian it's these people
it's these swamp creatures that are the
authoritarians president trump
is the most democratic transparent
element
in our politics in my lifetime and
frankly for a great deal before my
lifetime as well
and there are a lot of clandestine
operations going on
not just overseas many clandestine
operations going on
right here in our own country the
chairman of the georgia
republican party just came out and
tweeted quote
let me repeat fulton county election
officials
told the media and our observers that
they were shutting down at the
tabulation center at state farm arena
at 10 30 p.m on election night only to
continue counting ballots
in secret until 1am no one disputes that
fulton county officials
falsely announced that the county of
balance would stop at 10 30 pm
no one disputes that fulton county
election officials unlawfully resume the
county of ballots after our observers
left the center this is a pretty
troubling theme that's from david shafer
by the way highly recommend you follow
him on twitter
he's been giving a lot of great a lot of
great updates on all of this
what people keep telling us is that
listen you can't make up
ten thousand twenty thousand even fifty
thousand ballots
in in the discrepancy between trump and
bond you can't make it up on fraud
because fraud generally is pretty thin
that's true usually you cannot we are in
an unprecedenced
unprecedented situation with these
mail-in ballots this has never happened
before in our history
we've never had widespread unsolicited
mailings and so
because those are more open to fraud and
there's no evidence to the contrary
because it never happened before
you just have to use common sense here
because of that
and because we seem to find a i won't
say it's a coordinated effort but it's
certainly a coincidental effort
that republican poll watchers are being
kicked out
dramatically in philly even after a
court order they're being kicked out in
georgia where they kicked out elsewhere
too
we're finding out that glitches little
glitches in the in the machines of these
voting places
wrongly switched thousands of votes
from trump to biden because of software
that's used on 47 machines now the
election officials are saying oh that
was just a glitch
it was a human error we caught the
glitch just happened in one place no big
deal
well forgive me if i'm a little
skeptical of those claims
seem to be happening all over the
country all in these very
tightly contested races
we need to shed light on those things
we're going to shed light through the
legal process in the courts to see who
won the 2020 election
but we should we should be shedding
light on a lot of the
feted clandestine information that has
uh
gone around in our deep bureaucracy
for far too long politics makes very
strange bedfellows you know the idea
that i'm now
opposing a a guy who worked on the hill
he was a lifelong republican it seems he
says he was a conservative
served in the cia i do know people who
served honorably in the cia the idea
that we're opposing this now
is a little strange but those are the
circumstances that we're in that is
the kind of treatment that egg mcmuffin
and people like him have earned
even more bizarre i find myself siding
with a democrat in this case
joe manchin he's the closest thing to a
conservative democrat left in the
country
he's from west virginia so he has to be
president trump is still going to duke
this out
we did just get some good news that if
joe biden does ascend to the presidency
that if this georgia election does not
go our way if they find more democrat
ballots
that the democrats still will not be
able to ram through their agenda
because joe manchin a democrat will stop
it
if both of the georgia senators were
elected from
the democratic party then that would be
50 50 if
both dan sullivan and tom tillis win 50
50 means there's a tie
but if one senator does not vote on a
democratic side there is no tie
and there is no bill so i commit to you
tonight and i commit to all of your
viewers and everyone else that's
watching
i want to lay those fears i'm going to
rest those fears for you right now
because
when they talk about whether it be
packing the courts or ending the
filibuster i will not vote to do that
i will not vote to pack the courts i
think and i will not vote to end the
filibuster
brett this system the senate was so
unique body in the world
it was made to work together in a
bipartisan way and once you start
breaking down those barriers
then you lose every every reason that we
are the institution that we are the most
deliberate body
so i want to lay those fears to rest
that that won't happen because
i will not be the 50th democrat voting
to end that
filibuster or to basically bloc stack
the court
that is genuinely good news now listen
words
are just words until they're translated
into action so let's hope
that that joe manchin would stand by
that but i think what joe manchin is
seeing is something we all saw on
election night which is that
we were told there's going to be a blue
wave you remember that it's going to be
a blue wave across the country and yet
there wasn't
now after the election magically votes
are appearing that
are going to maybe swing a senate seat
or two but it didn't happen the
republicans didn't get blown out in the
senate we picked up seats in the house
and it sure looked like we won the
presidential election on election night
and who
knows how it'll turn out in the courts
even if we don't
end up maintaining the white house there
was no blue wave and the progressives i
th
many democrats believe caused that
shellacking
so a lot of more conservative or more
moderate democrats are now saying i
don't want to be part of that
well if if joe manchin says he won't
vote to end the filibuster if joe
manchin says
he won't vote to pack the court well all
of a sudden some of the most
radical proposals from the democrats are
gone something tells me he wouldn't vote
to make puerto rico a state or dc
heaven for fender state either that is a
little bit of good news
joe manchin explains what's he going to
be against what's he going to oppose
he says at this point he's basically a
republican and then all the other things
you're hearing about brett also is
the fund the police i don't know of any
of the democrats in the caucus
that are for defunding the police we're
not for that whatsoever
and when they talk about basically
medicare for all
we can't even pay for medicare for some
doesn't make any sense at all
we've got to fix the affordable care act
we have and i think our republican
moderate republicans will work with us
to now repair what needs to be repaired
also great news the thing is that
elected democrats have
very largely supported defunding the
police they've been pretty open about it
and just through the green new deal
that's a major radical proposal
that talks about redistributing wealth
it talks about
a medicare for all it just includes it
includes a health care plan then and
kamala harris the vice president
endorsed it she was she was i believe
the first senate sponsor of that
legislation
so there are some i don't think joe
manchin is telling the truth about his
colleagues here but
at least he's telling the truth about
himself hopefully that will lead to the
soul-searching some people thought you'd
get from the democrats
it won't lead to it on a party-wide
level but if you can
if you can chip away at one or two
democratic senators
that does help us politics makes very
strange
bedfellows we're in a situation now i
never thought we would be in
which is that the conservative
republican president hates fox news
trump
trump hates fox news
trump used to love fox news and fox used
to love trump
conservatives used to love fox news fox
used to love conservatives
now do you know who loves fox news brian
stelter at cnn we did talk about fox
news and he's very disappointed at fox
news at very crucial moments
uh the debate chris wallace is
moderating was terrible
really hurt i think uh the president and
then you know they called the election
they called arizona with 14 of the vote
in
many other networks never called it
meanwhile they wouldn't call florida for
hours
why what was going on at fox news that
they didn't want to give the president
the sense
that he was winning or had the potential
shot of winning
fox has a great decision desk i respect
their decision desk they don't
they don't they don't do it like that
they don't play games like that chris
i think media malpractice let's look at
the fox news poll it was off by
what eight points almost every poll
wasn't
the data coming out of fox was not good
at all yeah we're going to get into the
polls but but the fox
the fox poles were scientific they were
trying their best
i love the oh i love fox news yeah we
here at cnn man
last couple days man we've just been
loving fox news frankly they made us
blush a little bit
when they called arizona for joe biden
before
anybody and for no reason whatsoever he
said fox
slow it down i know you want to you want
to seem like us for a couple days but
come on so anyway in conclusion chris
and no we we love fox news over here at
cnn now
that was chris ruddy by the way uh chris
ruddy is the head of newsmax which is a
conservative competitor to fox and uh
newsmax has remained
quite conservative you know this
this changing of the guard this changing
of political perspectives on cable news
reminds us among these established
outlets there is no conservative voice
there isn't one
we thought there was but there isn't
it's
all against conservatives and now it
seems it's against the president
if you want to replace that established
media you ought to go to dailywire.com
become an all access member
that's our elite tier of membership and
and support that replacement media we've
got a lot of great plans this year this
is actually
my last show in my studio here
in los angeles i'm i think i'm basically
the last guy in the building
i'm going to turn the lights off behind
me we are heading to nashville we've got
some great plans ahead we're bringing
candace owens over
to the daily wire which has been in the
works for i don't know five years but
uh recently it's been in the works for
you know month or two we got some great
plans for her
and a lot of other people a lot of new
creative content coming out there so
make sure you head on over to daily wire
and subscribe
we'll be right back with a lot more
we are back we have to replace
the media i don't even think it's just
the news media we have to replace we've
got to replace
the hollywood media we've got to replace
all aspects of the media
i was heartbroken i was heartbroken the
other day because i thought
there are so few good guys in hollywood
forget conservatives i just mean guys
who are kind of balanced we're kind of
normal
who aren't constantly prattering on
about politics when all i want to do is
watch them in the movie or watch them in
the tv show
and chris rock not chris rock v rock
different rocks
the rock broke my heart chris rock
actually didn't break my heart he's
still pretty funny
but d rock dwayne the rock johnson broke
my heart
the rock came out he was kind of a
moderate republican he's now he came out
and endorsed
joe biden and that's not even my big
problem with him
the rock said that when joe biden won
he hasn't won yet but when joe biden won
when the media decided to call it for
biden
the rock cried uh i wanted to shoot this
yesterday
when the news broke but um
but i i got a little emotional uh
admittedly so i got a little emotional
uh yesterday
manly tears of course i may have cried a
tear or two or ten
uh but they were all very manly all my
tears have made me um
but the reason why i got emotional
yesterday was
was was because of what i felt my vote
represented
and i was talking to lauren my wife we
were talking about our two little baby
girls and
and that's exactly what my vote
represented my vote represented
my little daughters my vote represented
humanity my vote represented
decency uh it represented the values and
the principles
uh of which we we teach our little girls
and my vote also for me represented
the importance of just being a good
decent human being
so nothing that he just said
means anything it's it's it's as though
he went up to a platitude slot machine
and just kept he kept putting quarters
in you know he pulled it and he said
decency yeah i voted for decency and
yeah and my daughter is your daughter
whatever i guess we're all voting for
our family right isn't that
and yeah and cha-ching and cha-ching
decency
joe biden is a crooked liar
plagiarist one of the most notorious
in the country he is a complete empty
suit even if you don't like trump you're
going to say
we elected an empty suit who's a crook
whose family enriched themselves
by peddling american influence that
makes me feel so decent
my daughters are gonna love that why
your daughters like crooks why your
daughters like peddling american
influence i don't i don't think your
daughters probably care about the
election at all frankly
but people always do this they exploit
their kids for the election
that's what demagogues do he cried over
this
have you cried over presidential
elections asking the men
in the audience here have you cried even
trump i loved that trump got elected i
got such a kick out of that
i didn't cry and you know i hated that
obama got elected and i really hated
they got reelected
i didn't cry drank a little bit
i didn't i cry that's very embarrassing
we want to talk about a national
embarrassment
that's a that's a national embarrassment
to go out and say this publicly
but it seems to me that what the rock is
trying to do is position himself to have
a political career
i think that's why he's taking these
stands right now i think his
his calculations are pretty cynical i
think he was always a kind of moderate
republican there have always been
there's been a little chatter that the
rock might get involved in politics
again i'm just speculating
but i suspect that does describe
or explain why he keeps coming out with
these videos and he thought
he picked a winner and maybe he did but
he is now he's gone from being a
kind of moderate centrist quiet
republican to just parroting democratic
talking points
notably he had to hit the identity
politics he had to talk about how
wonderful it is that kamala harris
may be elected vice president because of
course
not because she's smart not because
she's ever done anything in her career
because she she is a woman
and not just a woman a woman of color
the second congratulations of course
goes to our brand new
vice president-elect kamala harris uh
the very first woman ever um to become a
vice president and certainly
the first woman of color uh to become a
vice president
as a as a man of color and as a man who
um loves and respects women uh this is
pretty special
so first of all again this little bit at
the end here sounded a little forced it
sounded like uh
i don't know like he was there was some
sub texture and as a man who loves and
respects women like i
love women i you'll never find a greater
supporter of women than me and they're
like
why are you defending yourself like that
pal no one's making any accusations
but then he he opens it up in this
typically
liberal way progressive way where where
it is better to be a woman than a man
and it's better to be
of color whatever that means than white
and so he says kamala here she's the
first woman
to be elected vice president and she's
certainly the first woman of color to be
elected vice president you say hold on
you're saying she's the first woman so
obviously she would be the first woman
of color
then you make a point you say and she's
certainly the first woman as if it's in
doubt as to whether we had a white woman
vice president
which i i suppose we could have had
hillary won and tim kaine became the
vice president i suppose it would have
been possible what is he referring to is
he making some kind of
snide remark about dan quayle yeah
kamala she got elected right i guess
again if the media are to be believed
maybe she didn't get elected then you
have to take this video down
and and that's the question that he he
gets to because he's assuming the
narrative that they've gotten elected
and then he says what does this mean
what does this vote mean this very
hotly contested vote that's going all
the way up to the courts what does it
mean for our nation you know what he
says he says
means we're unified we have had the
biggest
voter turnout in the history
of the united states and you know that
is such a big deal because
you know it tells me number one we were
unified on that day and just in terms of
everybody coming together every
everybody uh coming out to vote
uh mailing in your ballots doing
everything you possibly can exercising
the democratic right to vote which was a
beautiful thing
okay people did exercise their right to
vote maybe some cadavers
exercise that right too but the one
thing it didn't prove
is that we're unified this is a hotly
contested election
with lots of talk of irregularities and
lots of lawsuits
that even if these numbers are
completely right is one of the narrowest
elections at any level that we've ever
had in this country
that isn't unity that's division
and the left is not promoting unity
whatsoever give you just an example on
campuses
bates college in maine did a series they
did a series about voting in the 2020
election they posted photos to their
instagram account
of various student organizations and
various students one of whom
i know this is shocking one of whom was
a republican was the head of the college
republicans
there was a rally to pressure the
administration
to take the photo down the school's
president showed up to the rally
to tell the administration that he or
she runs to take the photo down
and then the school's president
apologized
for the photo because you're not allowed
to be a republican on campus you're not
allowed to be a conservative unc it's
not permitted unity
time for healing time for coming
together i don't think so i think
i i think they're they're giving us on
the left this kind of
soft rhetoric so that we will concede an
election that we should not concede yet
that hasn't played out the full legal
process
and something tells me that these lists
that all these people are making
the punishment lists the trump
accountability project the truth and
reconciliation commission tells me
those are a little bit more indicative
of what we have in store
if biden wins this election it's a
politics of division
the left always talks about this
politics of division and it's kind of
funny because the politics of division
sometimes
loops back on the leftists themselves
eva longoria
who it's a name that i've heard but i
actually don't have any idea what she's
done i know that she's
famous you know she's in hollywood or
something and i know that she's a left
winger
eva longoria came out she was
celebrating the election that the media
have already called
and she said the people we've really got
to thank here the real people that we
got to thank
are latina women here she is
the women of color showed up in big
waves of course you saw
uh in georgia what what uh black women
have done but that latina women were the
real heroines here
beating men in turnout in every state
and voting for biden harris
at an average rate close to three to one
and and that wasn't surprising to us you
know latinos are the ceos of the
households they make all the financial
decisions and healthcare decisions and
educational decisions
many latinas are small business owners
and they wanted a plan for recovery
um for themselves not for wall street
and so trump's policies were never aimed
at the struggling latina community and
you know
if you look at voter suppression on top
of that
how latinas showed up even through
through the closing of polling places
and the shutting down of drop-off sites
and new voter id laws and
long lines and driving 30 miles and and
all of that
and on top of that restrictions and
safety protocols of of a pandemic
that spirit and perseverance that
latinos use in their daily lives the
struggle to pay their bills and the
struggle to show up to their jobs and
homeschool their kids and take care of
their elders
that's the same perseverance and spirit
they use to show up at the polls
wow so brave and so many
lies in that statement so many
inaccurate statements first of all i
love
we now have the highest voter turnout
ever you know if if these numbers are to
be believed highest voter turnout ever
and yet the the liberals are still
talking about voter suppression
i don't think the vote was suppressed i
think when you have uh
71 and 73 or 74 million people voting
uh on each side i think the vote is has
not been
suppressed the other thing that drives
me crazy in her statement before we even
get to the meat of it is
she speaks english very well she speaks
english just as well as i do
except for that one word she gets to
that word which is a kind of contrived
statement i actually agree with some
leftists on this point that the idea of
the
latina or latino or hispanic rather than
people from specific countries like
guatemala or mexico or el salvador
the idea of the pan-hispanic thing is
kind of a contrivance of liberals to try
to create
racial solidarity modeled after the
black civil rights movement in the 60s
that's a bit of a digression
her pronunciation of the word latina
is ridiculous she is speaking english
and when you pronounce the word latina
in english it's pronounced latina
or hispanic or i don't know you could
get more specific on the nationality
it is not pronounced latina because
that's not how you say words in english
for instance i am italian i'm of italian
extraction sicilian to be specific
i speak italian i read italian i go to
italian restaurants
and when i go to italian restaurants and
i get my menu which is invariably in
english
i'll see some italian words there and
i'll talk to my waiter
even if the waiter is italian mostly we
speak in english maybe we'll chat a
little bit in italian mostly we speak in
english
and when i'm speaking and i order i say
okay yeah i'd like an iced tea
and i'd like a caesar salad to start
and then i would like spaghetti
and then i would like the the bread
pudding for dessert place
no i don't do that i don't do that even
though i get spaghetti
i could say that but that's very silly
and ridiculous because i'm speaking
english the same thing holds
for latina people should drop that silly
pronunciation
if you want to unit unify bring us
all together then speak english that's
fine but that's not what got eva
longoria in trouble
what got eva longoria in trouble is that
she focused on latino women
to the exclusion of black women she said
latina women were the real heroes
she didn't realize where latina women
rank on the hierarchy of victimhood
on the intersectionality scale they have
more privilege it turns out than black
women and so she apologized
and said black women have long been the
backbone of the democratic party which
as a as a
matter of fact is not true for most of
the history of the democratic party
white slave owners were the backbone of
the democratic party uh and
in recent history i don't i mean i
suppose black women do
vote democrat at large numbers but
you know the black americans are 12 of
the population something like that
black women about six and a half percent
so they may vote democrat
in strong numbers it wouldn't be the
backbone of the party right
because they're just numerically there
just aren't enough of those voters
but she had to pander to she had to
apologize and i'm perfectly happy that
eva longoria had to apologize before we
go today
i'd like to point out something that no
one is going to talk to you about today
because what we're going to talk about
when we think of our country is national
embarrassments
to use joe biden's phrase they're going
to tell you this country's awful it's
racist sexist you know bigoted evil
colonial i don't know whatever and
they're going to say the country started
in 1619 when the first slave ship
arrived in virginia but it didn't that's
not true
country started the following year in
1620. actually on this very day in 1620
when the pilgrims landed at cape cod
now they did not all disembark at cape
cod they then went down to plymouth rock
and we'll talk more about plymouth
plantation
when we get to that wonderful day in
history but today was the day
that the pilgrims landed in america and
the pilgrims founded our country
and they signed the mayflower compact to
all live together the pilgrims who were
these radical
protestant zealots and the the strangers
who were not particularly zealous and
some of them got into some bad stuff
coincidentally four of my ancestors were
on that ship
one of them was a very good upright
virtuous pilgrim three of them were kind
of derelicts
the strangers dr samuel fuller was the
pilgrim
and then stephen hopkins was one of the
strangers john billington was the first
man
executed for murder in the new world and
francis eaton was the the fourth one
those guys and the other passengers of
the mayflower helped to found this
country that's that's the starting point
and it's
when the 1619 project talks about
reframing american history they're
talking
they're not even just talking about
rewriting they are being honest they're
reframing it where do you put the focus
when you're making a movie when you
frame something you decide what you're
going to put into focus and how you're
going to adjust that lens
and that's what they're trying to do
they're trying to make you forget about
the pilgrims they're trying to make you
forget about the mayflower they're
trying to make you forget about the
first thanksgiving
they're trying to make you forget about
the mayflower compact and plymouth
plantation
and the the heritage that we took from
england
care of leiden in the netherlands all
the way here
they want you to forget about that in
favor of what
they want you to forget about our legal
processes for the constitution how to
conduct elections
don't forget about it have a toast today
to the pilgrims they probably would not
have had much of a toast they were
sort of tea totalers they had beer
because it was safer but uh
maybe you can have a toast to the
pilgrims today to hope to to very
difficult times that our country's gone
through
which the pilgrims certainly endured
half of them died in that first winter
and uh and to coming out better for it
to having hope
in providence which they certainly did
and i do too and we'll have to see how
it plays out in the short run
in the long run though i'm sure we'll
all be safe i'm michael knowles this is
michael knowles show
keep the faith that's the way that you
can be safe and we will see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire
20 20. hey everybody it's andrew clavin
host of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton